vous allez maigrir de 1 kg par semaine
un kilo par semaine rien qu en éliminant
le sucre 1 kg par semaine ça veut dire
que l' appui habituellement je perds
déjà un tuyau par semaine ça veut dire
que j'ai encore neuf non c'est pas ça
c'est un lion par semaine voilà en sorte
que minimum à mon avis tu vas perdre un
kilo par semaine et moi aussi si c'est
ça franchement tu vas me dire toutes les
semaines en à apprendre à pied ont
retrouvé c'est inquiète pas là de la
marche
dit bonjour à la grue ria elle est là la
grue était en train de regarder un match
de foot en fait je vois d'accord ils se
tapent le match de foot il vient de se
faire gauler regardais je ne crois pas
je le crois pas regarder je le crois pas
merci louer
vas-y vas-y
[Applaudissements]
la balle à baltard et qui fait quoi et
ce dans l'eau avec la balle alors elle
pas lui laisser de l'attraper ça veut
pas ce qui fait
oui mais petit bébé qui arrive à choper
des balles c'est par n au rayon insolite
le cheval les clients d'un supermarché
où thierry petites villes de sardaigne
ont eu la surprise de voir un équidé
déambuler dans le magasin sans oublier
de passer à la caisse le cheval auraient
été effrayés par un orage pour trouver
refuge dans la grande surface une fois
ressorti calmement l'animal a pu être
mis en sécurité avant de retrouver son
propriétaire
une course qui n'a pas manqué de serre
je vois qu'il réussit les hyènes trouvé
une technique pour monter avec
[Musique]
eux
un
terrain kai eide a été un guerrier un
gag
et poursuivre
office est bien traité quant à la fin du
mois tu peux plus mettre de pétrole dans
la gueule dans la chaudière et que
vraiment il fait 15 degrés chez toi et
que tu étais en faut des buts et drogba
paribas je peux pas mettre de pétrole
dans le truc c'est pareil pour tous va
effectivement j'étais donc 600 m² pas
cherché à compliquer à chauffer mais
c'est pas et que dans trente mètres
carrés j'allais pas de chauffeur à la
maison mais si je dis ça je vais
sûrement faire hurler
enfin
[Musique]
les prix de la suite ou du papier
toilette et des mouchoirs vont
considérablement augmenter dans les
semaines à venir selon michel edouard
leclerc la raison principale en un an le
prix de la pâte à papier a explosé une
augmentation pouvant aller jusqu'à 70 %
le prix de l'électricité à lui doublé et
celui du gaz été multiplié par quatre
résultat une hausse de 10 centimes par
rouleau et les consommateurs interrogés
hier s'y prépare je préfère avoir un 70
m² chauffer 15 600 m² froid je suis
désolé
parce que en fait dans sa 600 m² tu peux
mettre cinq familles donc c'est quoi
est-ce que c'est l'ego qui te faire et
c'est dans 1 600 mètres carrés mais j'ai
froid excuse moi je trouve les fumées tu
dis des bêtises
aux caisses où il a confessé faut faire
avec
débrouillez pour acheter les papiers
toilettes vous travaillez
comment on fait si non on oblige à
acheter bientôt l'être et comme tout on
prendra du papier journal si au bout
d'un moment
ma mamie alors j'étais prêt à tout sauf
à ça
[Musique]
des gens qui vendent en moins-value je
suis désolé quand tu bref des bleus - il
faut dégager la chaussée dessus qu'est
ce que je fais naret d'accord après ça
l'aurait fait si je fais quoi non mais
je comprends très bien ce que tu as tout
compris mes plans c'est jeudi à ce
moment là tu prends animalier même pas
de 60 jeux mais les gars m'ont éloigné
j'ai pu doser
là on n'est pas dans la série à deux
balles sur la tnt j'ai des fins de noter
sur alors zajac et gris
émission mauvais move également mauvais
vous le foot et ont revu à les terminer
donnez moi c'est quelqu'un de positif
c'est là